it's been a banner year for [ __ ]
especially with the success of Jordan
peels get out but for every movie that
gets its time in the spotlight there are
many that fly right under the radar
these are some of the most underrated
horror movies of the last 15 years the
descent this all-female flick is a
favorite among holder buffs but for some
reason it really gets mentioned in most
roundups the 2005 film follows Sara on
her way to a much-needed girls trip to
go exploring in a cave after the tragic
deaths of her daughter and husband
sounds like a great idea right
unfortunately the girls aren't alone in
a sunless cave add in the extra drama of
the frenemy relationships between the
women and you get a masterpiece of
tension claustrophobia and gross out
horror the house is a devil it's a
classic story
it's the 1980s and a college student
named Samantha accepts a babysitting job
where things just get stranger and
stranger
a 2009 horror release with director ty
West the house is a devil pays homage to
many classic horror tropes demonic
possessions the nervous babysitter and
the major twist that happened
surprisingly early in the film despite
its limited release horror fans found
their way to the house of the devil and
critics prayed that's cultural awareness
unfortunately they never found a
widespread audience the tale of two
sisters a dark version of an old Korean
folk tale that bears a strong
resemblance of Cinderella 2003 is the
tale of two sisters combines fairy tales
with all the wonderfully cryptic
elements of K Horrors and stands above a
slew of other fantastic Korean films
from the last decade of course an
American remake was released in 2009
under the title the uninvited do
yourself a favor and go straight to the
original thirst another fantastic Korean
horror film takes the form of 2009
thirst from old boy director Park
chan-wook with the story of a priest
turned blood sucking vampire parks
turned the undead fable into a delirious
romance while still offering off plenty
of scares though the film won the Jury
Prize at can in 2009 and debuted at
number one at the Korean box office for
American audiences the movie was easy to
miss if you haven't seen thirst or Park
chan-wook feather work give it a shot
you might be grossed out but you won't
be disappointed pong people after a
short theatrical run in New York with
Canadian horror movie went straight to
DVD in 2010 based on the novel pontypool
changes everything
pontypool tells the story of a radio DJ
who's determined to broadcast in the mid
of increasing reports of strange
behavior and violent deaths in a small
town a fascinating psychological
thriller about the nature of violence
inspired by Orson Welles radio broadcast
war of the world pontypool is definitely
a forgotten horror gem the loved ones
usually it's a male psycho or stalker
who creates all the problems in your
typical abduction type horror movie but
in this 2009 Australian horror movie
it's a girl named Lola and all she wants
is a date to the prom with help from her
dear old dad Lola abducts the object of
her affection it receives the torture
the living daylights out of commit their
kitchen table once it gets going the
loved ones never lets up high-tension
this excellent French slasher film turns
the genre on and Ted fans of blood
splatter will get more than they could
have dreamed up and everyone who watches
horror movies for their cultural
commentary will have plenty to discuss
after the movie as part of cinemas new
French extremity movements basically the
French version of body [ __ ]
high-tension is a shockingly scary as it
is psychologically disturbing making it
a horror film through the ages green
room the horrifying tale of a punk band
that finds itself trapped backstage at
their concert venue Green Room with the
toast of nearly every critics list in
2016 but outside of horror circles the
movie seemed destined to remain in
obscurity
luckily film distributor 824 stepped in
allowing the film to get a slightly
wider release with the fantastic cast
that includes Patrick Stewart and Anton
Yelchin three-room is a modern classic
worth checking out we are what we are
it's 2013 American remake of a 2010
Mexican film takes on a profoundly
disturbing topic cannibalism and with
this story it's all in the family but
the subject as tough as this one both
critics and audience members alike were
perplexed with the New York Times
calling it a dreamy commentary on the
ravages of extreme religious observance
despite its lukewarm reception we are
what we are is a well-executed stylized
addition to the modern horror Canon VHS
perhaps because VHS is an anthology of
short films rather than one narrative
film it never got much credit as a
horror movie most of the stories are
unnerving and several are downright
terrifying critics called the collection
uneven and the two sequels weren't quite
as good as the original but VHS is
definitely a unique modern twist on
horror lore inside critics praised this
french horror movie on this 2007
but mainstream audiences outside of its
native France never quite caught the
hype train due to its popularity among
dedicated horror fans an
english-language version was made by
Spanish director Miguel Viva and will be
widely released in Spain in 2017 but why
bother at the tempted remake the
original version is perfectly terrifying
as it is Evil Dead this soft read would
afford classic The Evil Dead is beloved
by diehard horror fans who know a great
thing when they see it it's both a
natural evolution of the series and the
completely standalone film with plenty
of nods to the original of course
possibly even gory ER and more
horrifying than the original Evil Dead
can't quite claim mainstream
appreciation but that's just fine with
critics and horror fans who have been
singing its praises for years thanks for
watching click blooper I kind of
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
checking all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]